it's speaking of racism we talk about
racism very often on this program and
most often we're talking about systemic
racism or racially tinged policies or
ways in which laws or policies are
applied in racially discriminatory ways
but every once in a while we have just a
good old-fashioned racist and republican
main governor paul lepage is exactly
that you might remember back in january
i told you that he talked about drug
dealers coming to Maine and he said
these are drug dealers named d-money who
come to our state and get white girls
pregnant absolutely insane comment to
make I mean makes absolutely no sense a
few days ago he was asked about these
comments during a town hall meeting and
he said straight up almost all drug
dealers that we are seeing in Maine are
black or Hispanic here's what he had to
say I don't ask him to come to me and
sell that poison but they come and I
will tell you that 90 plus percent of
those pictures in my book and it's a
it's a three-ring binder are black and
Hispanic people from Waterbury
Connecticut the Bronx and Brooklyn I
didn't make the rules I'm just telling
you what's happening I want to handle
this in two parts if I may first the 90%
comment and then the sort of bigger
picture of drugs in New England which of
course includes what the main number one
white people are statistically more
likely to sell drugs than black people
we know this okay let's assume what Paul
LePage is saying is actually true which
is based on this three-ring binder that
he gets or whatever ninety percent of
the people that they are arresting in
Maine for selling drugs are black and
Hispanic all that proves is that Maine
is disproportionately punishing black
and Hispanic people for a crime
disproportionately committed by white
people if I were Paul LePage I wouldn't
go around bragging about this and the
ACLU has picked up on this they filed
the public records request to try to get
a hold of this three-ring binder he
mentioned and I would be very interested
in taking a look at that now I want to
go beyond the 90% issue that he is
bringing up here
really interesting thing that's
happening around drugs here in New
England and that is around this opiate
problem that we have painkillers heroin
etc with crack cocaine the users were
characterized associated as typically
being black so you saw most of the
racially tinged comments around crack
cocaine and that epidemic focusing on
the nature of the users being non-white
however that line doesn't really work
with the opiate epidemic because the
users of opiates in New England in the
midst of this crisis are actually
disproportionately white so Paul LePage
and others have shifted focus from the
users who in this case are
disproportionately white to the
caricature of the dealers which Paul
LePage says are black but we know by and
large nationally are actually white
either way whether we're talking about
the users or the dealers people like
Paul LePage figure out a way to focus
only on the non-white people yeah I
assume that this binder is the same
binder that John karat made by the same
person that John Kerry's binders full of
women was made by Mitt Romney Mitt
Romney not John Kerry sorry Mitt Romney
but imagine if Kerry as Secretary of
State was walking around with that
binder full of women seems like
something more apropos of Anthony Weiner
by the way if you seen the news today so
okay that's that's my analysis of what
Paul LePage said one more note on this
Paul LePage makes news for his wild
public statements about race but the
real tragedy is the policies that Paul
LePage puts into place I don't want to
miss an opportunity to just focus on
these sort of shocking individual acute
comments because to be perfectly frank
if Paul LePage was a strong progressive
governor I would be way more willing to
excuse ignorant isolated comments that
wouldn't necessarily reflect on policy
although the fact that 90% of the people
that they claim to be arresting for
selling drugs are black and Hispanic is
certainly related to policy paula page
is a terrible terrible governor he
worked to repeal the ban of
finn'll a which we know is absolutely
toxic and carcinogenic to humans' he
made a proposal to change the
educational system to allow public
education funding to go to religious
schools he referred to the IRS as the
new Gestapo referencing the individual
mandate of the Affordable Care Act he
opposes abortion he tried to rezone 10
million acres in northern Maine for
development that would have been
terrible for climate change Paul LePage
is a dangerous extremist Maine voters
should get him out and while these
racially insensitive and outrageous
comments understandably get him into the
news let's not lose sight of the reality
that it's actually Paul LePage palapa
his policies that are really dangerous
and a reason to get him out if it's the
insane comments that puts him into the
spotlight and allows me to remind you of
how Maine voters need to go out and get
this guy out of office then I'm willing
to accept that but let's remember that
the policies are way worse than some
racist and insane comments that the guy
makes